a lot of the advice you know when it's
when it comes down to you know how men
should be with their friends you know
you've got to talk more you've got to
share more and I think I do think that
that men do need to do that more but I
also think that men and women both have
an issue around that I think men need to
share a bit more their friends maybe
women need to share a bit less can we
have that conversation you don't have to
tell your friend every single like
intimate detail of what's going on in
your relationship with a man because it
it's a real dividing line that I think I
I in my whole life I don't think I've
and there is a stereotype of menus to
criticize their wives I would not sit
with you boys of the night out and just
start trashing my wife I would I would
think that you would think less of me as
a man if I did that you would think that
he's treacherous he's disloyal you know
whereas whereas it literally is the
other way around broadly speaking for
women it's a bonding exercise if two of
them are trashing their husband the
third one might just make something up
just to be part of the game just so he
kicked me in The Shins here but did he
no I just I just wanted to have
something to add to to the chat they
want to seem you know I didn't want to
see him outside of of the group and I
think that that is there's always this
idea that men need to um like
emotionally correct to where women are
whereas I think there's actually
somewhere in the middle and it needs to
go on both sides there is a point with
blokes where I love going away as a
group of blokes and talking absolute
bollocks you know it's so um it's so
reduce that's what rejuvenates me is to
just not think of anything serious for a
while but there are points in my life
where you know a mate of mine will be
talking about his third kid and I'll be
thinking third
I didn't I don't remember the second you
know yeah that's that's it's not cool I
think we could and that's not like for
any great empathic reason it's just it's
not unreasonable to just be broadly
speaking up to date with the main
features of your pals lives because the
[__] hits the fan for them you want to
at least know the the name of the woman
that left him
I think what people don't acknowledge as
well is that there is a fundamental
difference like you said between men and
women and we need different things from
our friendships but I want to be able to
talk to my mates about you know things
that are not going well in my life but
when I see my mates like you said I see
it as a break from reality yeah I want
to go I want to have a laugh I want to
you know just talk about you know life
whatever it is I don't particularly want
to talk about me if I'm honest you know
there'll be banter there'll be fun why
is that Francis
because see if you did that on a night
out if you're like so what's going on
with you I would make me tense yeah it
did it made you tense it made me tense I
don't like it I mean what everyone needs
to be is there needs to be a long do it
while it mainly I don't like it yeah
feelings yeah well uh yeah I think that
there's definitely but there's obviously
Merit in both approaches yeah and that's
but maybe the argument I'm making is
that we've got to a point we're acting
like there's no merit in one approach
and total mirror in the other approach
because you know I I think you can
analyze problems into the ground I also
think that there are potential benefits
of you know blokes have nicknames for
each other oh yeah when you're mean to
another bloke it part when he's a mate
it's because you TR there's trust right
you can withstand it and I think that
you know I don't know many women that
have nicknames for each other probably
more working-class women have nicknames
for each other yeah but or or if they're
on a a WhatsApp group for a Hindu like
if there was people who are a bit late
paying would go come on you [__] more
you know use the kind of language that
bloats would say yeah to sort of chivvy
people up and put a rocket under someone
I think that there is a tendency to be
more agreeable you know as being
discussed quite a bit I just think that
neither are correct they're just
different approaches I don't understand
where one became bad I'm unhealthy toxic
and the other one just Escape scrutiny